here's a nice logic puzzle from
shakuntala Devi a family has several
children each boy in the family has as
many sisters as brothers but each of the
girls has twice as many brothers as
sisters how many boys and girls are
there
to work it out let's say the number of
boys is equal to B and the number of
girls is equal to G for each of the boys
each boy will have B minus one brothers
because you don't want to count the boy
himself then each boy will have G
sisters similarly each girl has B
brothers and G minus one sisters now
each boy has as many sisters as brothers
that means that B minus one is equal to
G
now each of the girls has twice as many
brothers as sisters that means that b is
equal to 2 multiplied by G minus one we
now solve this system of equations we
can substitute in so that we get 2
multiplied by G minus 1 minus one is
equal to G so that 2G minus three is
equal to G then G is equal to 3 and
since B minus 1 is equal to g b is equal
to four there are three girls and four
boys